In the Unites States historically, the main source for diagnosing mental
disorders has been the Diagnostic and Statistical Manual or the DSM. And this
is published by the American Psychiatric Association. This manual uses a
combination of scientific evidence and clinical observations to determine what
constitutes diagnosis of a particular disorder. The DSM defines mental disorder
as a syndrome, a set of related conditions. Of clinically significant
disturbances of thoughts, feelings, or behaviors. We want to point out that
this is an American perspective on psychological disorders, and therefore, it
may not encompass the perspectives of other cultures on mental health. More
specifically, the DSM 5, which is the latest edition of the manual, argues for
the 4 d's of determining whether something is a mental doisorder. Let's take a
look at each of these individually, while keeping in mind our continuum that we
discussed earlier, meaning the range on the continuum, from what's considered
to be acceptable, or normal, or normal variations in these categories. Or
what's considered outside of the normal range of these categories. So, the four
d's of disorders are disturbance, dysfunctional, distress or disability and
finally deviance.